[Music]  Melissa Joan Hart and Ryan Reynolds  could have been a 90s couple Ryan  Reynolds and a locked lips yeah we work  together and there was like a moment  where I stayed tricked them good for you  keep it back so sweet now we ready to  each other few times because we both had  shows on ABC and ran into each other at  like Sirius XM a few years ago and stuff  but I'm sure Ray's not Melissa and Ryan  were on-screen together for the Sabrina  the Teenage Witch TV movie Melissa was  asked about the potential hookup again  during an appearance on Australia's  studio 10 Friday morning he wasn't like  you know the Ryan Reynolds said  everybody knows these days he was sweet  he was very sweet I had a boyfriend at  the time but we were smitten and cute  and he was adorable he was he was really  really nice guy probably wouldn't been a  great boyfriend and I didn't end up with  the other guy so maybe I should have  taken a chance  [Music]